[Music]  drop the blaster  [Music]  give me the kid the kid is just my  maria's  whoever wheels this sword has the right  to lay claim to the mandalorian throne  you keep it i just want the kid  very well  [Music]  i see your bond with him take him  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  are you a jedi i am  god little one  he doesn't want to go with you he wants  your permission  [Music]  hey go on i'll see you again i promise  i hope you guys enjoyed this parody  video if you want to see more videos  like this one  please tell me in the comment section  below and don't forget to also like the  video  and subscribe so you don't miss future  videos  [Music]  you